es el mayor desasosiego de toda su
carrera así lo dijo el jefe de policía
de nara ciudad en la que sin suave fue
asesinado el viernes no es innegable que
hubo fallos en las medidas de seguridad
debemos llevar a cabo una investigación
exhaustiva urgentemente para aclarar lo
sucedido
la gente estaba visiblemente
conmocionado por el suceso en el que el
ex primer ministro recibió dos disparos
de cerca y es que en japonés en las
campañas se desarrollan en un ambiente
relajado esto previo a las
parlamentarias de mañana el país tiene
un bajo índice de crímenes violentos y
leyes estrictas para el porte de armas
es vino
no puedo creer que algo así ocurra en
japón en el pasado ha habido
apuñalamientos pero que alguien recibe
un disparo es inesperado
era muy querido por los líderes
mundiales y se preocupaba mucho por
japón todo lo que dijo resonó
nos ayudó mucho durante la pandemia
estoy muy angustiada y muy triste
el cuerpo de ave fue trasladado a su
residencia en tokio según los medios de
comunicación locales el lunes por la
noche está prevista una vigilia antes
del funeral del martes